what exactly is rent to rent it's when
you rent a property
under a business management agreement so
you don't rent a property to live in you
rent it off of a landlord on a
management agreement so you're paying a
monthly rent to the landlord now because
you're paying a monthly rent to the
landlord on a management agreement and
you're not living there
it means that the landlord doesn't have
any costs the landlord doesn't have to
pay a manager because you are the
manager
normally when you rent a property the
landlord's going to get the rent but
then he's going to have to pay
management costs he's also going to have
to pay maintenance costs guess what as
the manager of the property you're going
to take care of the maintenance you're
going to take care of the management
also the landlord might be worried that
he has void periods tenants moving in
moving out
spots of seasons where there's no tenant
in there and then he has to just get
paid nothing
so because you're offering the landlord
a guaranteed rent
on this management agreement where
you're the manager you're going to give
a reduced rent you're going to pay them
as small as you possibly can where the
landlord is still happy you're also
going to do this on a property that you
know has potential to change its use and
massively increase the rent and you do
this by turning it into a property that
is a hmo for instance where you rent it
out on a room by room basis or you do
this by turning it into
a serviced accommodation unit so you
rent each room out or you rent the whole
thing out but you do it on very shortly
on airbnb on booking.com so as a rent to
renter what you're doing is you're
paying the landlord let's say 500 pound
a month but you're renting the property
out
maximum rent for let's say 2 000 pound a
month and if you're a skeptic right now
you might be thinking
how on earth would you rent it out for 2
000 a month and only pay the landlord
500 because you've changed the use
you you're renting out room by room by
room by room or you're renting it out
short stays for a hundred pound a night
whereas the landlord he's just getting a
long-term monthly rent and you might
think well why would the landlord not
just do that himself and the answer is
because number one the landlord might
not have the knowledge
how to do it he might not have the time
he might have the inclination he might
have bad misconceptions seen some
negative press around service
accommodation or something like that he
just wants to get his monthly management
fee he doesn't want that but you as the
entrepreneur
as the rent to renter
you
maximize the rent you've put down very
little money maybe even no money or you
might have to pay a little bit for the
furniture or things like that to change
the use but you want to put down as
little money as possible and then every
single month you're keeping that monthly
profit
so renter is a very successful strategy
with many of my students you can make
anywhere between i'd sound you want to
be making a minimum of 500 pounds a
month profit per property that you do on
a rent to rent
so you got four or five of those and
that's replaced the average salary
and above the commercial building
there's two blocks of flats that's all
owned by the same landlord and one of my
students and he's actually secured this
direct to landlord on a rent to rent
basis he'll be making him around about 1
900 pounds a month profit when it's
fully talented he's just secured it he's
just secured some tenants let's find out
what's going on yes how are you doing
yes is that a tenant that is
so you're renting these rooms out like
crazy now i've got four rented out i've
got four left are you so you've
basically the downstairs is not yours no
but you've controlled the upstairs and
the top floor right complete show me
show me
so how much rent are you getting for
this entire apartment
so for this apartment alone i'm getting
2
800 pounds per month and i've got plus
the upstairs as well nice but i've had
i'm getting about 10 to 15 messages a
day
i want to hear the figures of this so
i'm paying the landlord 575
for to control the property so okay so
there's no voids for them guaranteed
rent i'm telling it for them yeah and
then the rent that i'm getting a month
comes to about 1 500 pounds nice and
then my expense is 9.50 so you're left
with about
five to six hundred pound yeah profit
yeah five actually that's decent bro
yeah for the first one i mean when did
you turn 18 just like two months ago
yeah two months ago okay so okay so this
this is right now for 368. yeah
um what about the other what about the
other one that you just rented how much
is that renting for so the other one
that's a 80s
okay cool so 368 346. what about the
other two rooms so they're both the same
at 90. 90.
and you've got a lot of interest in that
yeah i've had a lot of interest how long
recognitively before this whole thing is
just rented out
i've given myself a target of the end of
the week so and you only got the keys
last week yeah that's so good okay so
it's going to be 90 um
so you're going to get in total 389
plus
389
plus 346 plus 36a so you're expected to
make about one four nine two yeah so
sound about right yes you're gonna have
to pay five seven five five seven five
direct to the landlord which can leave
you with nine one seven but you can have
other costs as well what else yeah so
i've got to pay the council tax yeah to
pay the water gas and electric yeah i've
also got to put money aside for repairs
and voids yes
um and then there's also a small wi-fi
bill as well so that brings me to 550 a
month
is it crazy though that you're going to
be at university you're making 4 000
pounds a month profit
21 years old and you're going to be at
uni and everybody else that's at una is
going to be thinking i want this degree
so that i can then get a job which is
going to give me money but you're
already there on the money side yeah
it's amazing i do definitely think that
had i have come across you
potentially a few months earlier then
maybe i wouldn't be going back to uni
in october
about service departments you know you
came to crash course a few years ago
yeah started building their portfolio
stepped into service departments rent to
rent and they were like actually you
know what you don't need to just rent a
property you can go straight to a
developer and rent a whole block so so
we're standing outside the cube
the cube what's up so tell me about this
what what's that what's happening let's
go man this is 12 apartments there's one
two better the cube is full i think
we've got two rooms that are available
right now so it's like a hotel so it's
like yeah similar to a hotel where you
get a you get a kitchen and obviously
the space is a lot bigger than hotels oh
it's better than a hotel right
how much profit you expected to make uh
it always should i say is this expensive
i know you brought joint ventures and
stuff yeah how much profit is this
expected to make every month so at 70
occupancy
um wolf calculated about six to eight
hundred quid a month per
per apartment so wow yeah that's
okay times that by 12. so call it 700 on
average
per apartment times 12. she's expected
to make about 8 400 pounds a month
profit profit yeah in total which you're
going to share with she'll point you up
to investors yes how many investors you
pulled in seven months okay
how much money did you put into this
how does it feel being able to just give
give your fiance a job yeah she she's it
felt really good did it feel amazing
yeah she she's probably in tears
at the thought of uh we we actually told
our daughter that you know mummy didn't
have to go back to work and i think that
brought a tear to her eye
because
not many people can consider that
they don't need to work anymore yeah so
within uh the space of rinse rent
revolution beginning of august by
october i had 16 rooms
there it is
that is cool
bar properties
i'm really glad to see you doing well
done man it's so good i mean thanks
buddy you know
it's all with your energy and your
motivation and the hints and tips you
you giving us that's what gets us to the
next level basically you know
are your rent to rent mostly si or hmr
um i have both i have essays and i have
rent to rent our houses in this area
basically okay all our hmo properties 90
of them are in this area right we've got
one we've got field there a few on that
road few behind us
and those properties uh around here they
rent to rent property most of them are
entering ah okay so you've basically got
lots of rent to rents all around here
yes all around there yeah what would you
say to someone that said rent to rent
yeah it's too good to be true or it's
not realistic
well
this is an example we're in a rental and
property right so um it's doable it's
hard work but with the right coach and
mentor you can absolutely do it yeah you
know and it's just about you going out
there getting used to knows
because lots of people don't know about
renter but now people starting to learn
about it know about it now but when we
started if you tell someone rent to rent
they don't even understand what you're
talking about
yeah so we've got um how many different
landlords there's three different
landlords so um
two of the properties have come from
direct to landlord so that was through
um direct mail campaigns yeah and the
other three have all come through agents
so we call up agents find find the
properties we like and right move call
up the agents go for viewings with them
build some rapport let them know you
know that we're serious about what we do
and looking to take on a lot of
properties and then yeah then they just
they they basically could trust us and
we went ahead with the first one that
went really well and then they gave us
two more a two week rent free period
because we simply just didn't have the
money to pay yeah um so hold on so you i
had a landlord he agreed to give you his
property on a regiment basis yeah and
then you had to renegotiate yeah to have
it free for two weeks yeah yeah so how
did you do that what did you say to me
well what happened was we were going i
was going back and forth with him for a
very long time emailing calling trying
to break down the figures to him and say
this whole figure you're getting is not
what you're getting after the voids
after maintenance after all of that and
then finally one day you picked up the
phone and said um i want you to come
around my house and have a chat with me
so me and jordan put on our best suits
uh went round there um and we got
grilled and interviewed by about an hour
yeah um and then he gave us the keys the
next day so wow yeah so you obviously
you obviously handled yourself super
well yeah in an hour and i think that's
as well like you you guys come in from
position with very little money to
invest but then the little money that
you did have spending it on training
yeah yeah yeah so that then when you're
in a situation whereby you're getting
grilled for an hour
yeah yeah that's where the practice and
the training really comes in it does
yeah yeah yeah
so if you want to know more about rent
to rent you can ask questions below in
the comment box but also i am going to
be running next week
a free training program live in person
i'm doing a tour up and down the country
and i'd like to invite you to come
meet me in person and learn about rent
to rent so that you can become
financially free this year in 2021. did
you know that you can make money from
property without even owning the
property
this is possible through rent to rent in
the same way that amazon does own most
of their stock and uber don't own their
taxis and airbnb don't own their hotels
you do not have to own property to
control property and make money through
property i have helped so many of my
students become financially free by
controlling properties because they've
learned how to utilize rent to rent
stella has done it in oxford endrit has
done it in london tom has done it in
huddersfield and now it's your turn
where you can do the exact same thing
too in your city so come and join me on
the rent to rent revolution where i will
personally be sharing the secrets that
you need to become financially free via
rent to rent and the best part is the
course is completely
free what are you waiting for get your
ticket booked right now and i'll see you
soon
[Music]
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
you can subscribe up here also if you
want to watch more videos like this you
can check out a whole playlist up here
and i look forward to seeing you at the
rent around revolution real soon peace